y'all see the jerseys on my wall right
now right you see Herbert you see Garner
and you see Giannis okay I put my
Giannis up there right now because of
Damen little tree Dame time Dame time is
back oh man oh man Yiannis Dame time and
it kept Middleton now this is a serious
Trio this should not be slept on this
Eastern Conference side uhuh this east
side is serious the Bucks finish number
one without Game Time Imagine what they
do with him and they're going to spread
the floor and it's going to help Giannis
get more buckets yall know I'm going to
go up to Milwaukee and watch a game
because Dame doll is up there with my
boy Giannis it's going to be super fun
to
see